全部捨てなくちゃいけない
ありがたいと思うところから始め
もう捨てなくちゃいけない
私たちは捨てるのはどうでもいいところ
どうでもいいものはもう捨てるんだけど
ありがたいものは大事にしちゃうんだけど
それではもう一生頑張っても何回頑張っても
やっぱり観想する弱はなくならないんですね
そこでウパーディンナ・ルーパ
執着 まあ執着色っていうのは
そういう我々に煩悩を作ってくれる原因になる
悟らないようになっている
自害色あるいは ですね
まあ自害色など あの生まれる原因になる
現れる原因になる色の世界
サニダッサン 次に二十二
サニダッサン・ルーパ・アニダッサン・ルーパ
そこはもうまあ そんな大したことじゃないんで
で あのニダッサンなんていうのは
例を出す 例という意味で
この見える 見せるということで
こんなもんですよ こんなもんですよという風に
このちゃんと人に見せて説明できるということで
そういうのをまあ全部説明
物質の世界だから たった一つしか色がないんだと
それは目に見える色だけですと
ということで まあそれぐらいのことなんですね
他のものを見せることはできない
ですから 世の中で我々に見えるのはたった一つだけ
色は 二十八  二十八種類か
まあ十七種類か まあどっちでも数はいいんだけど
ありますが 見えるのはたった一つ
他のは一つも見えないということでも理解すればいいんです
だから世の中を見ていますにしても
世の中を見ているわけじゃないんです
いろんなものあるんだけど
見ているのはたった一つ
色だけ その場合 色っていうのは目で見える色
光に 形に それだけ この次の説明ですが
二十三の説明は まあ僕はちょっと
あまりあの 飛び飛び出していきたいんだけど
あまりに あの体とこの外の物質が直接触れるか触れないかっていう区別なんですね
昔こう考えたんです 例えば私は壁を見てるんだと
壁は目に 目に届かなくても見えるんだと
壁はそこに 外に 外に それそこにあってと
で 私は星を見てると 星は出てきて目に触れるんではないんだと
星はそこにいるんだけど
あそこに で 私が見えるんだと
でも私は何か味わいたいんだと
そうすると 味わいたいものはあそこにあるならば
ここでは味わうことはできないんですね
ちゃんと食べなきゃダメなんです
その差を考えてるんですね
ということは 私は星を見て
ああ綺麗な星だな 星ですねとか
いくら感動したっても星は減ることはないんです
で こちらに食べ物がごちそうあって
これすごい美味しいですよと味わってみようと
私が味わったら 他の人に味わうことはできなくなっちゃうんですね
で 綺麗な絵を 絵をこっち描けたら
十人見ようと見ようか
二十人見ようか 二万人それを見ようかと
絵は減ることはないんです
なぜならば その対象がそこにあって
こちらに触れることはないんだと
でもこちらには美味しい何か食べ物を作っておいて
豚一匹丸焼きにしておいたんだと
それはすごい美味しいんだと言うと
まあ十人来て美味しいと思うかもしれませんね
十人来て美味しいと思うかもしれませんだけど
百人来ちゃったら困るんですね
もう食べるものはないんですから
美味しいと感じることはできない
そこで対象がそこにいて
私はここで喜ぶと認識するっていうことはできないんです
その対象と認識する識のその区別をちょっと考えておこうというところなんです
こちらは 音の場合も同じことで
こちらに音があると それ何人聞こうと関係ないんです
音は減ることはない ですから
音と目に見えるものは
対象は遠くあっても構いませんと
でも体で触れるものは
舌で感じるものは やっぱり体にきちんと触れなきゃダメなんですね
じゃあ 次に大事なのは二十四番目なんですね
この分析の中での大変必要なのはこれだけなんです
今までの話はとっても難しいだけで
難しくはないんだけども
この四大識がありましたね
一番初めに説明しました
パタヴィ アポ テジョ ワヨ
地水火風という四大元素があります
四大識 この四大識っていうのは
決して離れることできない基本的な物質なんですね
それしか存在しない 今まで説明したものは全部もう実際の元々に存在するものではないんです
ただまあ組み合わせてそう見えるだけのことです
ずっと説明してたけど
この四つだけなんですね
結局あるのは パタヴィという質量を作る硬さと
アポというお互いに引っ張るエネルギーと
テジョという回転させる変化させるエネルギーと
いわゆる熱と ワヨっていうのは引き離すエネルギーという
素粒子的なエネルギーの波
四つ類の波だけなんです
その四つをまとめたら
物質の基本的なユニットが出来上がるんだと
そこでこの四つができたところで
もう四つ もう一つ もう四つ現れちゃうんです
それはワンナ ガンダ ワンナ
ガンダ ラサ オージャというんです
ワンナ ガンダ ラサ オージャ
このワンナ ガンダ ラサ
オージャと四つの色が現れますよと言っても
別に未だかつてなかった新しい物質が生まれたということじゃないんです
例えばあのクッキーあるでしょ
それを小麦粉と砂糖とバターと練ってオーブンで焼いたところでクッキーであって
別に未だかつてなかった新しい珍しいものがこの世の中で現れたということじゃないんです
ただ 組み合わせによって変わっただけなんです
そこで小さい花粉が組み合わさっちゃ
組み合わせ 組み合わせたら
そこにワンナっていうのは色
色というエネルギーの働きが生まれるんです
色 カラー 色 カラーという
カラーというものは生まれるんだと
どういうことかというと
やっぱりもう小さい花粉というのは物質というふうに言えないほどのものだから
その小さい花粉を４つまとめたところで物質が生まれるんであって
そこで時空関係 時間と空間の関係が生まれるんであって
そういうものが一個二個
どんどんどんどん大きくなっちゃったらどうなるんですか？大きくなっちゃうでしょ
そうすると そこに 例えば外から光がぶつかるんだと
ぶつかったらその光を跳ね返してあげることができるんです
光が跳ね返っていくんだけど
こちらにぶつかっちゃったら
このぶつかっ ぶつかってる面ですか
その表によって跳ね返る光の性質が変わっちゃうんです
ですから 何か表みたいな
サーフェイスというんです
サーフェイスは日本語になると表面
何が表面が現れちゃうんですね
しょうがない あの原子を考えるとよくわかると思いますよ
原子の核と電子の間はすごい大きいと最近聞いたんだけど
もしあの水素の原子が東京に置いておけば
もうつくばぐらい遠く遠いんだそうですね
あの電子がいるところ
いわゆるサッカーボールぐらい核が大きいと思うならば
電子が 原子一個の核をサッカーボールぐらい大きくする
そうするとそちらにぐるぐる回っている電子が
まあつくばぐらい遠く遠く置いとかなくちゃいけない
それぐらい距離があるんです
でもそこらに穴があります？穴が全くないんです
いわゆる核があって まあ水素の場合は一個の電子しかないんだけど
じゃあこの電子がないところで穴がある
全然穴がないんです ただエネルギーフィールドですから
核があって そこに一つのフィールドがありますね
そのフィールドを通っていくことはできないんです
ぶつかって跳ね返ってくるんです
別に物質があるわけじゃないんです
ですから 原子があって
そこにエネルギー エネルギーフィールドが出来上がっちゃったら
外の方からそういう風なエネルギーが流れてきて
これぶつかってもう跳ね返っていっちゃうんです
そういうことで 小さい花粉がまとめたところで
表面が出てくるということで
当たり前で別に 表面には表面の特色があるんだから
それに光というエネルギーがぶつかったところで
光というエネルギーがもう跳ね返って出て行っちゃう
でもそこで跳ね返ってくるエネルギーと出ていく光は違うんですね
例えばここに光がぶつかって
ここから光が跳ね返っていくでしょ
だからぶつかるエネルギー
光と出ていく光は違うんです
同じものじゃないんです
同じものだったら これ鏡になってしまっちゃうんですね
だから鏡を見ると蛍光灯そのもの見えちゃうでしょ
ということは ほぼ九十パーセントぐらい同じ光見えちゃうということで
百パーセントにはそれでもならない
ですから このある面が出て
表面が出てきて その表面に光ぶつかっちゃうと
光が跳ね返っていっちゃう
跳ね返っていく時 行く時はこの跳ね返ってる光が変わっちゃうんですね
その変わることによって
我々はこれはこれ これは机だ
これは椅子だと区別するんです
これはご飯だ これはパンだと認識できるでしょ
なぜ区別できますかというと
そのそのものから跳ね返ってくるエネルギーは違うんだから
もともとあるのは小さいカーフのみ
それだったらパンもご飯も同じなんですから
パンも石も同じでしょうに
小さいカーフだから それだったらなんでパン食べる代わりに石が食べられないかという
それ別な問題ですけど
とにかく我々には違うもので見えちゃうんですね
どんなものでも ですから
かすかにでも小さいカーフをまとめたら
そこに色 カラーが生まれるんだと
カラーが生まれるんだ
そういうことで 仏教では目に見えるのは
あの 科学的な世界で言えば色
光でしょ 目で認識するのは
仏教では使わない そんなことは
光と全然使わない 色というんです
だから仏教は原始的でわかってないなという状態ではないんです
ちゃんとわかってるんです
色と言った方が正しいです
光に敏感かもしれませんだけど
ポイントは光そのものじゃないんです
光は何かに当たったところで
映ったところで跳ね返ってくるんです
この跳ね返ってくるものの差なんです
大事なのは 照明を我々は花にも壁にも当たって当たると
我々は花のは花ですよと
壁は壁ですよ ちゃんとわかるでしょうに
当たってる照明は 照明は同じだから
同じく見えちゃったら困るでしょうに
ですから 目に入る光はあの照明の光
光なんです それなのに区別できるっていうことは
あの物質自体が何か光のエネルギーを変化しているんですね
それに我々は色をというんです
色ではなくて色 ですから
このパーリ語ではこの色はルーパというんですね
この場合はワンナというんです
言葉二つなんです これは漢訳になると
これも色でこれも色で
残念ながら同じ言葉になっているんです
ルーパっていうのは物質的なエネルギーということで
ワンナっていうのは単なるカラー
色 それよく すごく注意して覚えておいてください
だからこの日本語の単語は曖昧だから間違うんですから
別にもうそんなに大変難しいということではないんです
そこでパタウィ アポ テジョ
ヴァーヨという四つのものがまとめたら
まず表面が まずではなくて
一応表面が現れるだろうと我々には仮定できます
それをたとえ一個の原子にしたっても
それはものすごい膨大な小さいカフの集まりなんです
たった一個の原子にしたっても
膨大な量の小さいカフなんです
そこで そこにも表面が出ているんです
表面みたいなエネルギーが出ている
ですから たった一個の原子にさえ自分の色があるんです
見えないんだからないというんじゃないんです
もし一個の原子に自分の色がなければ
なんで原子がたくさんまとめたところで色があるんですか？あるはずがないで
それだったら それでこの化学の場合は
このちゃんと色っていうのは大事に考えているんですね
物事を区別する場合は色で区別するんですね
あるいは何て言いますか
この この光をあれ分けてスペクトルですか
スペクトラム だからこの遠い遠い星は何でできてますかと見る場合は
ただの光で色で見てよく言ってますでしょ
結局そんなもんなんです
仏教というのは やっぱり小さいカフができたら
そこにその人の色が出ているんだと
そのものの で ワンナ それはワンナであります
ですからワンナっていうのは別に存在しない
別に存在するものじゃないんです
小さいカフの組み合わせによっていろんなワンナが生まれるだけで
で 二番目はガンダ ガンダはこの香と香りと漢字で書いてると同じ意味なんですね
で 化学の世界ではこの香りで物事を区別するということはあまりやってないんです
もう少々はやりますけど
そんなにこのスペクトルみたいに厳密に発展してないんです
それもそれなりに それに訳がありまして
人間の嗅覚っていうのはすごく鈍くて
あまり強くないんです
人間にはそんなに香りはわからないんです
鼻がいわゆる進化してないんです
だからしょうがない もし犬が化学者になったならば
この色のスペクトラムではなくて
嗅覚の香りのスペクトル作っちゃうんです
そこで それによってものの区別というかもしれません
で でもその場合も やっぱり星は何で作っているかとはわからないかもしれません
なぜならば 星は目で見る場合は遠くあって見えますけど
香りの場合は自分で嗅がなければいけないんです
で とにかく小さいカフがまとめたら
そこに香りも生まれるんだと
いわゆる鼻で認識できるエネルギーも生まれるということなんです
次に生まれるのはラサ
味 味も生まれるんだ 味っていうのは舌で認識できるエネルギーなんですね
例えば何か口に入れたら
その入れたもののエネルギーのなんとかエネルギーが舌に伝わるんですね
この舌に伝わるエネルギーに我々は味と言うんです
鼻に伝わるエネルギーに香りと言うんです
それはもともと地水火風だから
地水火風しか存在しないんです
ですから 地水火風まとめちゃったら色が生まれてきて
香りが生まれてきて 次に味が生れてくる
で 三つ これは目で 色は目で認識できる
香りは鼻で認識できる
そこで味は 味は舌で認識できる
人間は それが膨大な量の地水火風なければダメなんです
では砂糖にしたっても
ほんの目に見えないほど一粒の小さいきめ細かいんだから
砂糖はね あれきめ細かい砂糖一つだけ舌に入れても全然わからないでしょ
いくらか あの大さじの大さじではなくて
小さじのまあ四分の一でも八分の一ぐらいでも舌に入れないと甘いとわからないんですね
ですから 我々の舌には膨大な量の分子がぶつからなきゃわからない
でも砂糖の 言葉は ない
で 砂糖の一番小さいあれなんて言いますか
この分子じゃなくて いいの
砂糖としてみると え？結晶じゃない
特殊な言葉なんですけど
うん え？分子 うん そう
まあいわゆる一番砂糖のね
まあこの分子一個とっても
それには甘い味があるんですね
分子一個には 甘いがある
味があるんだけど それわからないんです
大量にまとめたところで甘いというだけ
ですから 一個にも味ということは一応考えてほしいところで
ですから それは砂糖の世界じゃなくて
砂糖の分子一個にしたっても
そこにも大量の原子が入ってるんだから
原子一個見たってものすごい大量の地水火風が入ってるんだから
もう大変な世界なんです
そこで地水火風がまとめたら
そこに味があるんだと
原子に味がなければ分子に味があるわけじゃないんですから
じゃあそこまで行って次にちょっとややこしいオージャということなんですね
四番目に生まれるのはオージャなんです
オージャっていうのはこの滋養素という風に日本語で書いてあるんですね
滋養素 だから栄養と言ってもいいんです
栄養 栄養 なんかすごい即合なんですけど
そこで栄養が生まれるんだ
ですから このワンナは特別なものではない
ガンダーラさ王者の筆も特別なものではない
あるのは地水火風だけ
そういうのはただの特色だけなんです
そこで栄養という特色が生まれる
我々のは地水火風はわからないんだけど
これはわかります 栄養はわかります
栄養っていうのは この
なんで人間がね ご飯食べて草とか食べないんですかね
草やら雑草やら食べればいいでしょうに
人間はそれ食べないんです
我々はご飯食べる 動物はいろんな葉っぱとか食べている
そこで葉っぱには栄養っていうものがあるでしょ
その栄養っていうものは体に耐えるでしょうと
それで体が維持しているんだ
そこで 例えばライオンみたいな肉食動物は全然葉っぱいくら食べても
葉っぱにはちゃんと栄養あるのに
なんでライオンそれを食べないんですかね
牛と羊がちゃんと食べてるのに
牛では例えばカバとかゾウとか
巨大な動物も葉っぱ食べてあれぐらい大きく体を大きくしているんだから
ライオンも食べればいいでしょ
食べないんです わけは何ですか
ライオンは葉っぱ食べても
葉っぱについてる栄養はライオンの体にトランスファーリン
帰っていかないんですね
伝わらないんです ただ
葉っぱに栄養がある 栄養があるんだけど
ライオンの体にはその栄養がいかない
その葉っぱ食べてるゾウさんの体にはその栄養が入る
それでゾウは肉は食べない
肉には 肉には十分栄養があるのに
ゾウは全く食べない 食べたら死んじゃうんです
お腹を壊しちゃう で 何ですかというと
肉にはいくら栄養あっても
ゾウの体にはそれは伝わらないんです
いかない 届かない そこで私たちも同じく
ご飯やらパンやら もう普通人間食べる野菜やら肉魚やら
そういうものの中にある栄養が私たちの体に入る
だからそれを食べる でもどんな葉っぱも片っ端から食べるわけじゃないんです
どんな葉っぱも人間の野菜になるわけじゃないんです
木の実やらいろんなものを食べてますけど
何でも食べてますか？我々何でも食べないんです
食べたら死ぬものもあるんです
肉は食べるんだけど どんな肉も食べるわけじゃないんです
ということで でも それもうちょっと考えてみましょう
我々は米食べたら ご飯食べたら体に栄養が入って元気ですよって言うでしょ
そういうことは 米には何かエネルギーあるはずなんですね
でも米っていうのはもともと地水火風でしょう
他の何もないでしょう
他の他何もないんです
そこで地水火風と四つがまとめたら
滋養素という特色が生まれる
その滋養素の特色は エネルギーはある場所からもう一つの場所に移動する
それだけ いわゆる まあそれぐらいのことで
まああの科学的な知識あるならば何のことのない簡単にわかると言えますけど
米にエネルギーあるでしょ
じゃあ米食べたら我々元気になりますか？元気になるところは下痢になっても大変病気になるかも
お腹を壊すかもしれません
で 我々はご飯を食べる
ご飯になると米の量は少なくなっちゃうんですね
いわゆるこれぐらいの米ご飯にしちゃったら人間に食べられないんだから
大きい量が大きくなっちゃいますからね
一合とだけどかせるんですか？米はね
じゃあご飯一合食べたらお腹が満腹になりますか？満腹にならない
ご飯一合っていうのはほんのちょっとですから
大さじ 2杯ぐらいですから
米一合 米っていうのは一合というと
もうかなり炊いたらすごく大きくなるようなんですね
大きな量なんです 今はまあ一人は一合ぐらい食べられませんだからね
それぐらい量が大きいんです
ですから 半分四分の一ぐらい食べてしまう
ですから この米の量が
いわゆる小さいカーフの塊の組み合わせですね
組み合わせが変わってしまって
そこでご飯食べたら ご飯に入っているエネルギーは我々の体に入っちゃう
入ってご飯はご飯でなくなるんです
死んじゃうんです そこでご飯に入ってるエネルギーだけ行くということはないんです
ご飯の小さいカーフが体吸収するんです
そこでご飯の小さいカーフが体吸収しちゃったら
もうご飯はもうご飯の構造壊れてますから
もうご飯ではなくなっちゃいます
そこで他のものに吸収される
いわゆる持ってるエネルギーは他のエネルギーに伝わっている
その伝わるというか この
変換できるトランスレー
これそういうトランスはできるんですね
そこで我々にはこの外の世界で物質のエネルギーは体に入れることはできれば
そのエネルギーに人間は食べ物と言うんです
エネルギーはあるんだけど
私たちの体には入ってこない
そのものに我々は食べ物と言わないんです
ですから ライオンには生肉は食べ物であって
葉っぱは食べ物ではない
人間の食べ物は他の生命の食べ物ではないのです
食べ物っていうのはどういうものかというと
この体を構成している物質に必要な小さいカーフ
変えるんです それを食べ物と言うんです
体が小さいカーフでできているでしょうし
で 小さいカーフっていうのは止まっていない
流れ去ってしまうんです
流れ去ってしまったら
新しい小さいカーフを入れなくちゃいけないんです
それだったらどんなものからも小さいカーフ入れちゃえばいいんだけど
そうはうまくいかない
ある決まってるものから小さいカーフ
小さいカーフをもらわなくちゃいけないんです
体から小さいカーフ出来ていく
そこで私の目の前に机があります
机も小さいカーフなんですね
だから私の体から出ている小さいカーフの分を量を机からもらおうと思ったって貰わないんです
私はそれをパンやらご飯やら他のものやらもらわなくちゃいけないんです
もし私は小さいカーフ
この机からもらうようになっちゃったら
私はこの机を触っている間は
机はどんどんどんどんガタガタに悪くなる
消えてしまうんですね
ご飯食べたことと同じくなっちゃいますからね
パン買ってきて そのパンのエネルギーは自分に使いちゃったら
もうパンは存在しないでしょ
その働きなんです エネルギーはある場所から違う場所に移動する
その場合は小さいカーフ丸ごと移動する
その移動は違うんです
例えばこちら こちらにある空き缶はゴミ箱に入れる
その移動 とは違います
空き缶はゴミ箱に行くだけで空き缶はそのまんまだから
でもパンの地水火風は体に移動するということは
パンそのものの構造は壊れてしまうということなんです
その移動なんです その移動できる
その可能性に滋養素というんです
ですから この滋養素あるのはご飯だけじゃなくて
一切の物質にあるんです
空気にもあるんです 溶岩にもあるんです
だから地獄に落ちたら地獄の鬼たちは溶岩食べさせてくれると言ってるんだから
別に気にする必要ないんです
向こう行ったら食べ物は十分あるんです
[笑い]地獄に行くのは怖いと思っている人はいるんだけど
別に食べ物ないわけじゃないんです
あるんですから とにかく人間には溶岩食べられませんだけど
やっぱり溶岩であろうが空気であろうが
もうどんなものにも 鉄そのものにも
金銀も ものすごいフォスフォラスとかいろいろあるでしょうに
すごいもう恐ろしいものさえ
そういうものにもちゃんと地水火風だから滋養素あるんですけど
人間にはそれはもう入らないだけです
そこでなんでウイルスやら微生物は他の細胞なんたかに依存していますかというと
例えばO157とかがいて
そこら辺どっかでいればいいでしょ
なんで人間の腸を侵しちゃいますかというと
そこら辺にいても そちらそこら辺にあるエネルギーは自分の体に伝わってこないんです
移動しない ですから エネルギーを移動できる場所に行くんです
エネルギーは移動しちゃったら
元のところ 元のものはどうなるんですか？壊れるんです
それはしょうがないんです
エネルギーこちらにもらったんだから
私たちはご飯食べたことと同じなんです
ご飯にあるエネルギーは我々の体には移動します
と同時にご飯は壊れてしまいます
ですから O157が体に入っちゃったら
体の調子が悪くなるのは当たり前であります
エネルギーもらっていくんだから
その そのプリンシプル
原理をこの滋養素と仏教でオージャと言っているんです
ですから オージャというのは栄養なんですけど
仏教ではすべての物質にその栄養素はあるんだと
で この梵天なんかに生まれたら物質ではないんだけど
この神々なんかはもうなんか
違う食べ物を食べているんですね
人間には食べられないんだと
神々食べるものを人間食べたらすぐその寸時に死ぬんだそうです
それぐらいもう大変なもの
神様はヒエヒエだ そこで光食べてるんだと
香り食べてるんだとも言ってるんですね
で 香り食べられますかと
私たちはちょっと首をひねっちゃいますけど
香りと言ったっても地水火風でないと香りがないでしょうに
その香りを作っている地水火風のエネルギーが吸収できる
そうすると香りは消えちゃう
もう香りは香りなくなっちゃう
例えば光食べてる場合は
光っていうのは地水火風なんですね
そこで光をある神が食べてるならば
そこでその神に当たった光は全部消えちゃう
ということになるんです
そこで光を食べて生きていられる人々っていうのは
我々には想像できない状態
違う存在ですからね 光エネルギーにしているんだから
といういろいろなことで
光というのは我々知っているこの太陽の光線でもないんです
太陽の光線はある ある
それとしての流れだけですからね
それはまあ それだけ光じゃないんです
いろいろ光があります
じゃあそこでこの一番この物質の話はだいたいそこら辺で終わりかもしれませんだけど
一番覚えてほしい大事な物質っていうのはこの四つであって
その四つにつなげているこの四つの特色なんです
地水火風という四つと
それにつなげているワンナ
ガンダラ ソージャ 色 香
味 滋養素という四つの特色なんですね
ただ特色もアビダラマのいいところ悪いところがいいところはわかりませんけど
全部物質扱えているんだから問題ですけど
その八つにこのアビニボーガ
アビニボーガっていうのは何ですか
ふかぼんぽんでした ふかんべつ
ふかんべつ式と かんべつ式と
[背景音楽]